I've been playing zombie army for dead
war this week wholesome fun for the
entire family
[Applause]
there's nothing more satisfying than
exploding a zombie's head well unless
unless it's his junk it's dead before we
start I wanted to thank rebellion from
the bottom of my zombie fueled heart for
sponsoring this video for some reason
YouTube doesn't love zombie Nazi subject
matter but now I'm free to show as much
gore as I like there will be blood oh
yes indeed and most likely a zombie
shark or two if you like what you see
I've included a link below for more
information
now the disclaimers are out of the way
here's ten reasons why you should keep
an eye on zombie army for dead walk of
course we have to start with the
brilliance of the internal kill cam a
staple of the Sniper Elite Series which
has become the calling card of rebellion
games and just as you would expect this
is hands-down the most addictive part of
killing wave after wave of Hitler's
undead minions if you've played the
previous zombie army trilogy you'll
notice and upgrade to the detail inside
the zombie carcasses exploding stomach
spleens or simply just breaking bones
this doesn't get old I enjoyed it so
much that I change the settings to show
these sniper slo-moes even more often or
more frequently I should say we're going
to talk about co-op play very soon but
one thing is apparent here if your core
partners aren't aiming their weapon
in-game you'll all be treated to the
slow-mo bullet damage showcase complete
with your sniper name for all to know
who hit that dirty shot
I deliberately found myself lining up
multiple zombies so one sniper shot
could take out multiple enemies please
tell me this is satisfying to see if it
isn't I may have issues because I love
this
as we're already talking about headshots
it's a good time to point out the
importance of those headshots the undead
can continue their march towards you and
your teammates with limbs missing with
internal organs bullet-ridden this makes
head shots imperative throughout your
playthrough it's the only way to 100%
know that they won't get up again each
of the zombie horde can be willed back
to their feet to fight a dark magic so
keep your finger on your trigger Oh in
fact there's another way to take them
down the curb stomp hell yeah we can be
the World War 2 version of Seth Rollins
smashing the skulls of every member of
the undead we see as well as it's being
another addictive mechanic this will
also save you ammo and if we can dig in
far enough some zombies will drop items
from ammo to health to grenades and
other throwables too
[Music]
throughout the sprawling missions in
zombie army four you'll encounter
contextual kill opportunities well to be
honest they aren't contextual they are
fully constructed killing machines built
by other survivors each machine is
activated by a well-placed shot to this
target bot and then sit back and relax
from electrified floors to slow down
huge groups of the undead to aeroplane
rotor blades which drag in enemies and
grind them to a very satisfying
hope just don't get too close the blades
don't like that my favorite contextual
murder spree has actually come at the
hands of a zombie shark electrified into
spasms of action beautiful my first
playthrough of zombie army 4 was
completed along a solo run the
developers have mentioned how they
improved the long wolf opportunities for
gamers and I'm the type of guy who
prefers to play alone when I first
started game but something happened I
was not expecting genuinely scary
sections let's quickly point out that in
team play or even co-op with only one
other player there are zero horror
moments which strike fear but something
happens when you play alone as there's
more time to look around
simple exploration can reveal four
nerving elements for example the freaky
dolls found on each mission made me feel
on edge and this was added to tenfold in
a mission which could have come directly
from Resident Evil 2 a military bunker
so claustrophobic with limited lights
infested with these scurrying little
things which can literally pop out of
any hole on any vents anywhere on the
map I guess what I'm saying here is the
atmosphere and playing alone is
intensified and I for one think the
experience is superior in solo play
which is strange to say isn't it when
this is a co-op shooter
[Music]
so let's chat about the multiplayer and
the co-op experiences playing the games
campaign a second time with a pal is
indeed a great deal of fun
the missions don't change from what I've
noticed but tactically everything
changes having a sniper on overwatch as
another player runs in for shotgun
shenanigans or using one player to round
up a heart for the other play to throw a
grenade in there's so many ways to play
with a friend there's something about
knowing that we can be revived if the
worst happens adds a layer of catharsis
to proceedings on the other hand in hard
mode co-op play is imperative as
surviving on Hard difficulty alone it's
close to impossible well for someone
with my skill set anyway the hard mode
is effectively call of duty zombies in
third person trapped in a location with
constant waves of zombies marching
forward as each wave is completed more
of the level is revealed inviting more
of the undead to join the battle
each zombie-type slightly changed with
different weaknesses and attack patterns
for example some mid tier enemies need
their heart literally ripped out of
their body or destroyed rather than the
usual headshots were used to and others
like the snipers will stay so far away
only counter sniping will help I found
this is the mode which we kept coming
back to again and again and as I'm
writing this rebellion has said that
free updates to hard mode are coming
soon
epoch came a moment
[Music]
let's go back to enemies for a moment
from the base infantry zombie - this
clicker inspired abomination the breadth
of foes have massively changed since the
zombie army trilogy but some enemies
come equipped with weaponry we can pick
up after motorizing them there's an
oversized flamethrower which is great
for taking down gangs of the undead
another heavy will bring a gun straight
out of Terminator 2 which absolutely
shreds everything in its path and for
up-close-and-personal beatings may I
suggest the buzzsaw and Uwe bladed death
machine which colors the screen read
with putrid blood on top of all this our
weapons in the world such as mounted
guns a rocket launcher and this the
preacher shotgun all breaking up the
sniper plate which keeps the game
feeling fresh even the base weapons can
be reworked with mods and upgrades one
upgrade uses arc electricity to spread
through the zombie ranks and another one
adds good old explosive damage weapon
variation is definitely here should you
choose to play that way
[Music]
as you'd expect every game in the world
has cosmetic items and soldiers zombie
army for it's filled with customization
options but these must be unlocked for
an example this badass cap was found in
the very first mission of the campaign
after crossing a bridge to NPCs were
inevitably going to die but luckily by
helping them out and keeping them
breathing they kindly opened a safe and
gave us a weapon mod and that awesome
hands from that point it is now in our
locker for the next time we play another
great way to unlock cosmetic items is
via the weekly challenge just as it says
it will reset and change every seven
days the one I encountered the week
before the game released is to unlock
this weapon skin I was tasked to play
through the first mission on the
campaign on medium difficulty with after
shotgun or AR luckily it gave me
unlimited sniper bullets so there's pros
and cons to the weekly challenges I have
to admit it adds great replayability to
zombie army 4 and gives gamers something
to work for which we all yearn for
inside now I'm just waiting on a bright
pink weapon skin or maybe I'll let your
dorm ask if you're listening fingers
crossed
nope so after everything we've looked
through there's one thing on-screen
constantly which also plays into our
addictions the combo meter killing you
multiple enemies will skyrocket that
number and the amount of times the
desire to keep it going upwards has
pushed me to run headfirst into action
is ridiculous
there are even perks to keep the meter
running to help give time to reload and
continue towards greatness from our
first point to our last point
nothing beats slow-mo sniping whilst
building a combo meter there's something
addictive that
[Applause]
so that's my week with the zombie army
for dead war an alternative timeline in
which Hitler some of the undead zombie
horde rebellion have announced the first
round of DLC after the game launches
which includes new campaign missions and
a whole host of other things let me know
if you'd like me to break those down I'm
more than happy to do so once again a
huge thank you to rebellion for their
sponsorship on this video allowing me to
explore game mechanics to Gori for
YouTube I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade it's been an absolute pleasure
I'll see you next time hey you stayed
until the end well just for you here is
the greatest sniper shot ever seen enjoy
oh that's beautiful
I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]